we had in a sense a very good
relationship with the civil rights
leaders and the civil rights leaders
were always critical of what we were
doing and always thought we weren't
doing enough I think they were quite
right and taking that view but we
couldn't figure out how to do what it
was they wanted us to do or that that
was in the interest of the country to do
it we we did a great deal but the answer
had to be legislation you had to have
not the president not the Attorney
General involved in this not even the
Supreme Court with a brown case and so
forth he really had to have the Congress
and the people behind this you weren't
going to get any worse until that
happened and that was what we were
trying to do and thanks to dr. King and
the many people that worked with him in
those that peaceful demonstrations that
he had thanks to television for showing
what the local sheriff's offices and
police officers were doing finally
people said this is wrong and we were
able to get that legislation not by
Democrats but by Democrats and
Republicans working together
difficult at times
music a great leader deserves enormous
credit for what he did wouldn't be where
we are today we wouldn't have succeeded
in the 60s without the leadership of
Martin Luther King he was difficult only
in the sense that he wanted you to do
what he wanted you to do and you
couldn't always do it I don't know what
Americans understanding of the civil
rights movement is if I had anything I
wanted to correct it would be this that
the abuse of blacks in this countries
started long before the constitution
with slavery we couldn't resolve it in
the Constitution we couldn't resolve it
with a civil war in 1860s it continued
to be a blemish on this whole country
and what was important to get people to
understand in the 60s and it's still
important for people to understand the
day that civil rights is not doing
something for African Americans it's
doing something for all of us because it
is building a society that doesn't have
stupid prejudices that can listen to
other people that can tolerate
differences that's the country we have
been and that's the country we should be
I think we've made an enormous amount of
progress but we've also driven there's a
lot of bias that still exists and
there's a lot of inequality that still
exists there's a the black middle class
has done very well and so that you you
know you see movie actors you see judges
you see lawyers you see businesspeople
you even see some CEOs and that's all
good but you also see far too many
african-americans in jail far too many
african-americans unemployed and we have
to do something have to continue to do
things that try to lift the bottom to
get it closer to the middle